welcome to this 25-minute game let's get
going 25 10 second increment let's check
here Eric bongos from the Nerds so we
got a Sicilian yeah I play the open the
soil it will be kind of a dare but what
is it who dares wins something like that
okay what is he going to play higher the
dragon hmm hmm okay dragon you really
have to know well with what to play
especially this year the is made nine
yeah I'm going to play with this that's
a sideline with g4 but quite an
interesting one but to be honest I only
know that it is quite interesting but I
don't know how they how it is continued
after that i'm not mistaken bishop e6 is
the main continuation now now and he
goes for that now castling law it
shouldn't be bad
yeah thinking be 14 night wait that is
all it's possible right I'm not
stumbling into some some silly tactical
now 95 is the idea 95 Quint XD 297 check
so he has to react somehow
there was some positions here and
notoriously tricky and especially if you
have no experience like yum like you're
like me can be very quick way to lose
stuff running into some kind of kind of
technical trick
so he's saying that night d5 Quint xt2
it's no big issue that's probably true
hmm we should f6 Bishop F 695 Queen no
Tim that's also not particularly great
he is definitely threatening would take
C 3
95 22 and that leads to absolutely
nothing so maybe I have to play a 3 here
to UM to continue
I can always just go like H 4 and so on
that standard attacking themes I have my
fair share of experience with trying to
play the white side of the helps a
dragon in in blitz chess mostly and
against people who know what they're
doing I always had huge problems because
it's just so tricky and if you don't
know that that motifs um can so easily
be be crushed
yeah I don't know what is blacks idea
Luke p 8 and b5 huh seems to be so if I
go
maybe I can play b5 only and 95 on their
own only after years played b5 ok start
with this but after be five of Wi-Fi can
maybe go for that transposition no
transformation not the transposition
now I mean I think I almost have to if
he goes b5 he threatening before and
that that's totally Vader I have to do
something with 95
you know
question is 95 immediately on and let's
verify I think I really have to wear
before it's still strong that's too
strong I have to go 95 something like
that just wonder if I really should play
it now on Bishop f6 first special at six
Bishop F 695 22 Knight f6 I can even go
King g7 down and it's nothing great and
the move like g5 he will go before I
that's well that's not going to work for
me so let's do that
what idea was to only play that that
transformation with the 95 in a
situation where he already has be five
plate so that there's actually Bishop e7
in the position and so I know that
there's there's some things to attack
yeah one question is how should he take
now I think you should take on d5 but
how exactly 90 xt5 co-ed 5 we should be
for loop the floor then Bishop d7 that
it's maybe a little bit better provide
that position but it's nothing
extraordinary
Bishop g5 ed5 that looks a bit better
for white yeah with the with the two
bishops
blacks position is fairly solid however
it's not it's not going to fall apart in
a couple of moves or so and it's only a
slight slight edge for white anyway so
how would you continue is h5 an idea it
takes a g5 my that's probably okay I
think it's it should be helpful to gain
that space
it is probably okay even before it's not
terrible now or maybe it is no now you
can play it I thought for a moment I
thought bishop a6 might be might be an
issue but it really isn't no problem
one idea of h5 can be h 6 h-6 Bishop
back g5 he moves the night I take on age
8 play Bishop age 3 those kind of ideas
hi case going ave voluntarily okay if I
take on g6 now and I can let sue first
and then think
if he takes with the H pawn it looks
normal maybe I take g7 rook H tours a
bit of an annoyance maybe it's not as
bad as it looks at first you cannot go
look a Jedi trait everything take b5 but
I'm not threatening a maid or something
drastic yet
still looks difficult so let's do that
Teague and playbook age too he cannot go
gauge eight as I said and I'm
threatenings they move like g5 that's
really a thread
and Luke age seven check King f6f voice
also a thread there is some an
interesting no really I can go to age
five yeah that's definitely true
definitely true I was thinking gee 50
but he can go to h5 bishop age three and
then Bishop g4 or something like that
now that's not not that great
let's let's do it like that g5 he has to
go to age five otherwise I make make
could work here on him Brooke age 7 and
meet so he has to go there and I was
thinking is maybe be formal or is that
crazy trying to fix that porn I Lucas
III in some as an issue
hmm tricky tricky tricky tricky Bishop
e3 yeah that's probably not leaning too
much Luke c5 Bishop g4 look t5 take a
couple of times they are on age five and
now that's not it's not going to going
to be so dangerous f 40 Bishop e2 many f
for loop c5 Bishop g2 maybe and then
Bishop f3 next
and not easy for if he goes rook h8 that
when f5 that's a very kind of technical
way to do it no but maybe maybe it's
good I don't know F for Roxy 5 shop g2
then Bishop f3 maybe next look age 8 f
five if you then move the night
somewhere f6 check winning a look hmm
maybe but I feel something might be in
there for him some opportunity that I'm
not fully appreciating it
before yeah a form i was thinking a for
keeping things on the board if i take he
is god i have to go in for anyway taking
it rook takes makes everything look very
silly on there on the Kings side
Roxy 5 Bishop g2 and then maybe Roxy
forehead could be a drawback of my whole
concept here it's very shaky when I'm
playing here since not it's not entirely
convincing at all we should do and then
now that a five move it's not leading to
much if I've immediately here's not not
working at all
okay i can go Bishop e2 maybe this is a
wise choice Rock t5 Bishop h5 take
stakes then try to do something with the
active rooks all right let's that still
fields rather not very promising but I
wonder ever have something else really
Bishop g2 is got a look-see for and my F
for porn for partisan is an issue so
let's do it it's probably not going to
lead to much but don't really see what
else again it cannot move the night or
take because I book h7 check your king
back and checkmate into but rook takes
d5 looks totally okay
now I think he probably should play it I
don't see Luca Luca Luke age eight is
probably interesting try to trade off
one look in the process that could be
interesting and no he's doing something
else going for some kind of counter
attack all right it's a bit risky I
guess
so Bishop h 5 g takes rook takes rook c2
and then f5 that's very dangerous for
black that's probably a huge euphemism
no I can do that
yeah that's good I can go kingi six
maybe
hmm
see thinking of an alternative I don't
believe it well there's no other move
yeah he has to go King g6 and I guess
and this is not entirely clear Roxy to
f5 I think loses straight away don't see
how he defends against through cage
seven and so on yep you had to do this
and now
let's let's check direct tactics first
like f5 Teague's g6 check that's not
going to work though there any other
ideas rope 2h7 look-see to work x.x
checking f5 looped xf7 check kingi for
that's very very tough to evaluate
position
one issue is that you will just take on
d5 of course if I play something
something slow here
No
not quite sure what to do look aged 7 is
the the sharpest move which forces
things quite considerably but I have to
be a bit alert after root xe2 he has
ideas like b3 and made me on the back
ranked at can draw candor can blow blow
blow up in my face very quickly that
kind of thing but probably I don't
really see any other move that rook age
7 seems to be the only one that gathered
promises promises something checking on
h6 King f5 look aged 7 is also an idea
trying to take things with check of all
the time
hmm
let go look 12 age to look T 5 f-5 check
king cakes i have g6 funny tactic but
you can check with the rukon f5 and then
i have nothing this the don'ts don't see
anything decent
rook age seven again oopsie to anything
else then checking on age 6 that's
really really risky continuation but at
the end King edge we are maybe maybe
that's really nothing going on ok let's
let's do it yeah I think Luke c2 looks
mandatory he has to get get counter play
rook takes d5 rook 12 h 6 and then that
that's no good so he has to chase it too
yeah he really has to take you to nurse
not much else I guess
I can think about other ones by Arab
takes it too looks like the most normal
way normal move ever
yeah i'm going to play rook to h6 wow
really that fields really passive I can
play look look 12 h to at least but i
can also grab stuff let's grab sheriff
really no reason not to check
the Jeep on is really really dangerous
yeah probably i can just promote the
jeep on and ignore that the sea to pawn
is hanging yeah I expect King you for
now and then g6 I don't really see how I
stop that point g6 rooks e to g 7 he has
to check on c1 b3 is threatening me
though ok I can cover the first rank
yeah i think the GG porn is just
promoting I don't see how he stops it
I had he absolutely had to take on c2 I
think you played really ok up to that
point it might be it might be good for
one anyway but it's it's not really a
case where you have a choice you just
take on c2 and hope for the best
okay so is there any reason to not play
g6 CL
g six books e to g 7 g 3 i'm going back
where the couch could stick could be
slight issuers
the reason why I'm hesitating is that I
definitely have alternatives I mean look
to h2 is probably probably very simple
move but also good move oggy 6 check
King f3 is also possible
yeah maybe Luke h2 also wins and then
March the Jeep on i really ask Louis the
dough I don't see what he what he has
then if I just do this
hmm
hmm i'm lazy as usual i'm very lazy in
those positions do i really need to
calculate all that i think that should
win technically and g6g seven maybe I
could have played just g6 g6 look-see to
g7 my look G g6 Roxy to g7 rock g2 that
irritated me I cannot promote then
directly anti-squat rook 7c to that is a
strong counterplay so maybe investing
that mafia is in fact a good decision
and Jeff I don't really see a whole fam
if he takes her d5 with the rook I was
thinking then g6 roop d1 checking a tool
rook g one g seven then look aged eight
and promotes yeah so we can we can test
that line basically or rope no look II
to doesn't make any sense really so
let's push it
so look do you want check King a to look
g one g cell okay is tossing that that's
a it's a interesting tribe trying to
play look the one King ever take it
rookie one checking a to rook 72 m to
see one but i have before to stop any
ideas from made so rather annoying that
as still as possible oh okay if I go g7
here
g7 takes on c2 rock cakes it's not even
checkmate right so g7 is something that
I probably should not play and yeah so
much for that off um yeah so I have to
take it look you one King a to rook
seven to see one before check on a one
king be 3r ugh d three check King z4root
e4 check hmm ok I probably run all the
way to d7 yeah it's hard to win any kind
of position if you're too lazy to
calculate and maybe I'm guilty of that
again
yeah I don't really see an alternative
to Ruby one rook see one
any other move I don't see it really
don't
check it's easy at least so now before
is the only move I don't I mean okay I
can theoretically speaking Czech imani
seven but that looks weird so before
check on a one can be three rogue d3
check I can even go back to see two
that's probably better with him
it takes before to see threaten anything
i think i can just go g7 but hmm
well i guess so i can just go with your
seventh don't don't really see a
substantial thread go all the way there
there you just got quite some checks but
i'm always escaping now so g7 will be
the next move I guess
I can start with the check on a one but
it doesn't really help i think yeah I
think that's the that's the that's the
line that is a bit more bit tricky I'm
let's say so we'll g7 huh
yeah don't see don't see why I shouldn't
rook jomon yeah so now one one thing
that I can do is I can take e seven with
check he cannot take the f porn because
of rook f to check and then I'm
promoting was check after rookie seven
he has to um yeah move the King to to f5
or to f3 so that that's a possible move
what else I can also yeah I mean I think
taking on his seven should be good chats
not overthink thanks him one little idea
is some no but not a good idea I was
just thinking let's say King f3 I can't
play something like rook age 12 trade
one pair of books but it takes g7 then
it's kind of unnecessary to go into
so.2d three hmm
yeah why not it it gets nearer my my
king and my turn introduce some some
tricks okay so um
look h8 4g8 promotion
you cannot go king situ or anything as
rook c7 esses ending the whole thing
then rook a one checking v3 after that
he doesn't have a doesn't have a check
even it's got look hbu 10 that's also
not a threat no so would then just Luke
aja town to promote
yeah I've spoiled a fair amount of
positions that good when it came to
really am young calculating it to the
end so I'm a bit I try to be cautious
double check things and so on that's why
I'm taking a bit of time your gauge it
really looks like a win but as I said
sports so many good positions I really
don't see see anything here for him b3 I
will take and he doesn't even ever check
or anything so I don't I don't see it I
think white white should be a winning
here in this in this position
oops
black resigns oops yeah I was away for
just a quick moment from the desk and
while coming back he simply threw in the
towel I am probably correctly so let's
let's have a recap of that game he
really put up a very good fight um yeah
I don't know the opening this is why I
went a three I think that is probably
right rooks III as a threat and 95 here
let's say it's not leading anywhere i
had this kind of thing here like this
end game that's I don't know maybe black
is better here he has this opportunity
my name on a very good day and why
doesn't have a clear idea so this move
rupee eight yeah maybe g5 now I don't
know that's the computer suggestion not
a bad idea ok I don't think that this is
bad take stakes yet here I'm not sure
about Bishop takes but ok I'm not very
much at home in that this position so
some some caution is advised with
trusting my ideas him I was rather
expecting this kind of thing but he I
didn't think that this should be like
this that this should be anything
special the engine likes white but not
not by much yeah and this snow h5 went
back
I a g5 is an interesting alternative I
played it in a somewhat straight forward
straight forward manner Knight f6 that
was good i guess this and therefore we
are very yep very straightforward so he
went be form of course you can never
take that chat let's made yella
checkmate so it's mostly between Roxy 5
and before before a for Roxy 5 yeah we
should be true yeah and now the computer
gives rook age 8 as good I think I
mentioned that during the during the
during the game that i feared that this
was a good move when it is a good move
so I played and played it badly early
and this is this is the problem if we
think about this position here my rook
is misplaced I've got problems his King
can activate and this is a quite a big
porn this is a very bad position and
that wasn't i plated too I know a little
bit too simple-minded yeah we're pushing
the pawns and so on that isn't the way
it should played rook c8 however all of
a sudden um is ok for me that is the
right move and now I went here he played
rook c7 I think after that it's
basically over I thought he has to take
him check check check and then this
position this is a I really didn't know
what what how to assess this properly
here um he's got these ideas of putting
the rukon the side and coming here so
let's say I take it he does this yeah
Teague's takes a and he's got at least a
perpetual and this is the problem it's
hard to avoid this I can can I do
something else i mean i can try like
this this and drop back secure the first
rank as he was threatening be three but
again yes this is doubling ideas g6
rooks ec2 g7 maybe four drawer yeah
that's the draw Black has to frost the
draw but he has it where he has a draw
so looks it to us what he has to do and
after this i still am probably just
winning Luke age too yeah so it's g6
winning let's check I wasn't entirely
sure takes yeah wookie seven that was
something that I saw when I thought in
comparison that I'd rather chances good
now according to the engine but this
isn't that clear right look g2 I wasn't
sure about this I have got this move
that's strong am ok check and I did it
so it seems that the Jeep on wins as
well but this is a technical win let's
say without many many lines to calculate
or things to go wrong you know the
engine is just check giving a total win
so I think that was okay at the end but
the problem was that here at the
beginning of the middle game that same I
chose I chose the wrong plan I probably
have to improve around here not because
a not for big edge or something but to
not be worse and the way I played it I
really was much worse if he finds this
here this Luke h8 move I'm in trouble
can I do this yeah then this move comes
my pawns are loose it's just just like
that ok I hope you enjoyed that game
thanks for watching